welcome
everyone i'm anja winfield your
moderator for today
i'm not a string marketing director in
email
and i'm really happy and excited to
introduce the webinar today
we are focusing on neuroscience today
today is the third day
uh it's the third day of the spatial
trilogy special answer trilogy
we focus on oncology on tuesday
yesterday we focused on immunology
and today is the turn of neuroscience
please note that this is a live webinar
so you can really post your questions
there is a q a box there on your screen
please use it and we'll be very happy to
answer your questions
our guests speakers will be taking them
on
live at the end of the presentation so
the session will run as follow today
first of all we have
about 10 minutes um
of a technology introduction this will
be presented by my colleague
tonight zuka from nanasing a specialist
of geomix who will introduce the
special genomics revolution with the
geomix digital spatial profiling
platform followed by our very nice
colleague
and friend powell from the illumina
company who will talk about the
incomplete the workflow of
spatial genomics after these two
presenters i will introduce you
to our guest speakers for now i just
tell you that one of them is professor
philip kitovic
professor from the center of
neurobiology and brain restoration
from the skullcover institute of science
and technology in moscow
and the other presenter is the john leu
senior research
fellow from ucl queen square institute
of neurology in london so now over to
you
tony and pablo thank you
great thank you very much enyase and
thank you everyone for joining us um
we're really happy to be here and um
we're looking forward to showing you
some
uh we have some great guest speakers
here with some great data
i'm going to start off a little bit
about the geomix platform
our spatial technology and the geomics
and nanospring as a whole we really have
a way to
make the biology simple but give you
incredible data we've gotten
over 4 000 publications with 1700
different
signatures and we're really proud of
that
but finding the right biomarker can be
really difficult how how do you do it
and classically especially with the
encounter nana strings initial
technology
it's really powerful with this example
that was done in collaboration with
merck
where it was bulk expression found in
18g
signature really important for a
companion diagnostics and they were
thrilled about that
but if you look in the bottom right here
there were still some genes
some patients that had an up regulated
signature of these 18 genes
but still didn't have improved
progression-free survival
and why is that what could help tease
that out
we think it's spatial gene expression
where you can draw an roi
around a highly hot but excluded tumor
highly infiltrated tumor or maybe that
bulk gene expression would struggle
but you can really see the
differentiation with um
the geomics and the spatial capabilities
what the geomics can do at a high level
is fresh frozen
ffpe rna and protein
high plex capabilities of 18 000 gene
whole transcriptome with human or mouse
100 plex protein and an roi selection
that's quite tunable
there's no trade-offs with the geomics
but how does it work
well it works by having photo cleavable
linkers and we can attach that to
antibodies we can attach that to rna
probes
when uv light hits this these probes are
released into this
into solution and we capture them and
then count them
with rna we are doing basically for the
whole transcriptome
18 000 ish experiments all at once
which means we're really robust in ffpe
of course we can do fresh frozen
that's the easy stuff but we're not
doing poly a capture we're doing an
unbiased uh targeted approach and
work really well in these difficult
matrices
the whole process goes where we have
those
photo cleavable linkers to uh be either
attached to an antibody or attached to
an ish probe
then we mix them with fluorescent
antibodies
which i call fluorescently labeled
morphology markers because you mix the
profiling reagents with these morphology
markers
and then you that number two you select
your rois based on the morphology
illuminate with uv light you then and
number three
will cleave those probes and then you go
to the next roi with
a new fresh buffer and then you release
those probes and everything is collected
into a 96 well plate where that plate
goes downstream to be counted
and then you bring that back to be
analyzed
with some really interesting software
tools on the geomix
as a whole what the geomix is its beauty
is
is its simplicity you're getting this
whole transcriptome or hundred plex
information but it's all simplified by
defining your rois early
you can decide exactly where
uh where you want your data to come from
you could be comparing
astrocytes around a a particular plaque
or a particular cell type
but because you defined it early then
when you start looking
at your whole transcriptome information
the data is easier
in this example here you're seeing a
list of genes
and those lists come back to us with
counts
and then each of these counts is then
traced back to a particular roi and our
software can work through this
and or you if you have the biostats
experience
you can work with that yourselves
and i really do think that that
simplicity
of being able to define things early
also
our reproducibility is what's gotten us
into so many
um journals in general in just the year
and a half we've been working
but also high impact publications nature
medicine
nature and the last slide is just kind
of a reminder the strengths of this
platform
is fresh frozen and ffpe it's protein
100 plex protein 1800 plex
whole transcriptome human 22 000
whole transcriptome mouse tunable roi
selection whether it's just an roi a
circle
or if it's a single cell population that
you want to illuminate
there's that kind of throughput and
definitely
we can do four to ten slides in a day
and then now i'll pass it over to you
paul
thank you very much for this very nice
introduction to the geomix platform
and my name is
i'm part of illumina's marketing team
and it's my great pleasure to
within the next couple of minutes
briefly introduce
what we are and what we offer
and as tony mentioned the the readout
for the high-tech geomic
assays is done on illumina sequencing
systems
and this is a truly exciting field
it was selected as the nature methods
method of the year just a couple of
months ago
and it really shows how exciting this
technology is
so biological systems organs they of
course have a precise organization
because it's important
for their function and being able to
look at expression within this tissue
context is
truly valuable because it gives an
additional layer of information
and it can really tell you more about
the underlying
biology i wanted to start with a
brief introduction of illumina so for
those of you who haven't heard about us
we are a global company
and we develop manufacture and market
innovative next generation sequencing
and microarray
technologies and our technology enables
you to make foundational discoveries
but also to transform medicine and
ultimately to impact lives
and there are more than 200 000
publications where our technology has
been used so it clearly shows that this
is a robust technology
giving you data you can trust and you
can either purchase a system and
implement it in your own lab in-house
or you can also turn to one of the many
service providers found
throughout the world and get access to
our technology there
in our sequencing systems they are a
very flexible
tool and depending on how you prepare
your samples
how you do the library preparation you
can use the sequencer to study
several different types of biological
molecules
so you can study different uh facets of
dna you can study different populations
of rna you can do studies at
single cell level and it's tony very
nicely
illustrated you can also do spatial
profiling look deep into tissues with
retained spatial information
and our system fits very nicely with the
output needs of the nanostring
geomic dspsas
so for example the the the larger
geometric assays the cancer
transcriptomatist
allowing you to look at 1800 genes and
the whole transcriptome atlas
allowing you to look at all 18 000 genes
they are an excellent fit
to our nexiq and novaseq
sequencing platforms
and of course data analysis is also an
important step
and we want to make it as streamlined as
possible
so now on base based sequence hub which
is our cloud-based environment for
sequencing data storage and analysis
there is now a
geomix pipeline
so the this application this app will
basically take the the sequencing reads
and it will uh it will convert these
analyze these into a digital count
conversion file
and you can then take this file and load
it onto the geomix
dsp instrument to do spatially resolved
analysis
and different types of visualizations
and of course if you have any questions
about our
sequencing solutions our technology
please don't hesitate to get in touch
so with this thank you very much for for
joining us today and i will
head a hand the word back to amiese
thank you very much paul thank you tony
and we
just uh proceed on and i'd like to
introduce our first
guest speaker professor philip kaitovic
who i
invite on the camera now and let me tell
you a little bit about the
biography of philip and so philip
completed the undergraduate studies in
molecular biology at moscow state
university
followed by a phd in biochemistry at the
university of illinois at chicago
philip worked as a postdoctoral
researcher at the max planck institute
in the department of evolutionary
genetics
tilly took a faculty position at the
institute for computational biology
jointly established by the chinese
academy of science
and the max planck society in shanghai
in china
philip was then promoted to the
institute director tradition
and from 2012 philip is a fellow member
of max plant society of germany
as well as a junk professor at shanghai
tech university in shanghai china
and from 2014 is also full professor
at the very famous kotek institute in
moscow
and the presentation today you see there
is the transcriptomic map
of schizophrenia thank you philip take
it away
thank you very much another uh today i
will talk
about the transcript of schizophrenia
schizophrenia is a disorder which needs
no introduction
unfortunately it affects about one
percent of human population
and but still despite decades of
research
uh we don't know the mechanism of
disorder to detail
and because of risk we cannot really
design
good treatment or good prevention
therapies
and the part of the reason we cannot
really easily identify the causes of
schizophrenia because it affects the
brain
and the brain is incredibly complicated
tissue
which contains uh about 100 billion of
neurons
and each neuron connected to the other
neurons by
1000 to 10 000 connections so when
some people compare our brain to
computer
it's totally an underestimate we should
compare our brain to a huge
internet this may be
100 billion users
of course it makes very difficult makes
it very difficult to identify the
reasons for
any disorder and always include
so molecular causes which could be
reflected by gene expression
so in our work uh before we
turned to the geomex analysis we did
some
background work we use the conventional
rna sequencing
to build some kind of equivalent of
transcriptome map
of the schizophrenia and control brains
we took number of brains
from schizophrenia individuals and all
individuals
and here you can see the actual slices
we use some of you heard about
gray matter and white matter of the
human brain and you can see it really
exists this is a slice of frozen brain
from collection which we use and
we talk about 35 different functionally
and anatomically different brain regions
if you can
uh here you can see the map of these
regions
so there were regions representing our
cortical areas which shown here in blue
dark blue green and light green but
there are also cerebellar ridge and
subcortical regions from human red
white metal regions shown in purple
and some deep nucleus file
uh you can see here in orange
and uh we did conventional rna
sequencing
to get the data and then compare it with
statistical analysis and i'll show you
the main result of this analysis
it is here i apologize for the quality
of slides because it's work in progress
perhaps it's a little bit too small to
read
but immediately what you can see what
with certified brain regions listed here
and here the bar shows just number of
differently
expressed genes also this direction but
direction here is not so important more
important than numbers you can
immediately see what the numbers are
very different
and among brain regions and actually
there are some
favorite uh schizophrenia brain regions
most neuroscientists use
is a rodman area 9 and broadband area 24
with some parts of the frontal cortex
here and the cingulate cortex which
is between two hemispheres
but actually if we look at them uh
we will see very few differences so with
letters here if you is it not too small
for you to read this ba-9
you can see it's here and other ba
areas such as brodman areas of the
uh cortex the neuroscientist who named
viserys lived about
100 years ago and he distinguishes areas
based on their
uh histology composition of different
layers of the brain because our
cortex is just a layer cake and they
still
this separation still makes sense
because with different uh
errors they play different roles and
outbreak
and you can immediately see what among
all rodman areas there's just one with
green one which stands out
this is uh broadband area 22 the one is
here and the temporal cortex
and all this frontal cortex area and
pareto cortex here
being white blue or dark blue they don't
really show as many differences as one
would expect because
till now if you look at the bulk of
transcriptome status of schizophrenia
uh maybe ninety percent of the papers
would examine
either broadband area nine or some other
part of the frontal cortex
we also find lots of differences in
amygdala and this is rather expected so
neuroscientists already knew what
amygdala
is involved in schizophrenia uh but we
also find a lot of differences
and also in both cerebellar regions and
this is really not something very well
started so
already here we see quite a lot of
new things but of course so for us most
interesting to investigate things which
happened in the cortex
and uh so we looked at the two article
areas
uh broadband area nine which is the one
which has very few differences
in our analysis and this actually agrees
well with previous data
because even though many people looked
at it
frequently different labs get different
results
and this is not so surprising because if
you have very few
small differences it's very hard to
reproduce and broadband area 22 in the
temporal cortex
it's not really investigated in
schizophrenia at all
so we with the help of nanastring
which we are grateful for we were able
to
take a look at these two areas and not
only investigate
bulk expression of course because it's
special but we will be able to see
expression in different layers of the
cortex remember i told you it's
like a layer cake and so there's six
different layers
neuroscientists usually distinguish
from the bottom to top six five
four three two and one uh overall
there's quite a lot of genes could be
detected but we selected very strict
cattle
which from around eight thousand
eighteen thousand five hundred genes
overall detected we looked at about
uh one thousand two hundred because we
wanted them to be
highly expressed uh which is still a
very big number of things
considering we should work with a
spatial analysis and first we
compared the differences which we see
not the expressional genes
but it's important we compare the
differences which we see
between schizophrenia and controls in
two brain regions in broadband area nine
you can see it's here prefrontal cortex
versus lethal brain
uh and this is frontal part of it and
the broad monarch entity which is here
part of the temporal lobe and
why it's important because if we look at
the papers even using bulk rna sequence
and just the conventional
conventional rna-seq
very frequently there is no correlation
between the differences
reported by one study and another study
and uh
part of it because in some regions there
is a there are a few different societies
like broadband area nine
and indeed here we see quite a
weak correlation but still significant
so
which is very good it means what despite
the fact that there's very few
significant differences
we still can reproduce them using
nanostring technology
but the broadband area 22 which shows
more differences
of course it looks much better so the
correlation
between the ball carbonated and the bulk
nanostring
which is now pulling data from different
layers
into this kind of pseudo-bulk expression
their correlation looks quite obvious
and of course it's highly significant
but more important for us do we see
different number of differences
so to say in each layer for instance
because we know
different layers of the cortex they have
very different function and brain very
different
histological architecture and indeed we
see that
so if we look now more closely this is
now
number of differentially expressed
drills in different layers from one to
six
in the broadband area 22 john here in
green
or bradman area 9 shown here in light
blue
and you can immediately see what
actually even though
in foreign area 22 we obviously see
more differences and this is now just
not a string big this is your next
whole transcript on sequencing uh and
this is a significant differences this
is not some kind of detector chance
so we see a significant difference in
statistically significant differences
and we see first of all what in
agreement with our
bulk transcriptome analysis broadband
area 22 shows more of his differences
but we also see
what most of his differences that is the
majority are in upper layers and layers
one
two and three especially two and three
and in a way
in the broadband area are nine we see
similar pictures there's also
some differences scenarios uh four but
uh
this is the layer six and there are five
uh to some extent they show
much fewer differences then the
next uh
next uh
interesting analysis again i apologize
for such small
figures i hope you can read them but
this is cell time comp
composition analysis because we know
what brain consists of different types
of neurons
excitatory inhibitory and
osteoastrocytes
and here we were able to look at the
marker genes which
show which are characteristic of
astrocytes
of exceptional neurons and inhibitory
neurons
and they hear the stars so indicate
significant differences in schizophrenia
and one thing which we clearly can see
with astrocytes
so they called astrocytes because they
look like stars and they support the
neurons
they really very clearly obviously
decrease
in the middle layers of the cortex
but the neurons both excitatory
inhibitors are increased
so the differences which we see there
especially in the layers two and three
it's a combination of signals so which
we uh which we get from astrocytes and
from different types of neurons
in addition to uh transcriptome data
we were lucky what nanostring helped us
to generate the proform data
and so we also looked at with two
areas at the proton level and here it's
a different order so don't get confused
this is a region 22 and
region 9 sorry this is
built in opposite order but nonetheless
the result is the same
we see more differences in um
uh region 22 compared to region 9.
you can see the layer distribution is a
little bit different
in for rna it was um area
uh layer two and layer three mostly and
here's layer one but this is also very
important and interesting because in the
cortex
frequent the cell body is sitting on one
layer but the protrusions of the cells
for instance axons or dendrites of
neurons which contains a lot of proteins
they actually can extend and do extend
to other layers
so here's the discrepancy between the
rna and protein data is an additional
source of information
and the last thing i wanted you to show
some rather striking examples of
differences
which we were able to see based on the
protein data
for some very well known neuronal
markers
such as vimentine so here you can see
the control in schizophrenia
and here you can see the layers 22 and
the nine
and the differences in the layer 22 and
much bigger than the layer 9 but
actually layer 9 also has differences
so people who were starting before and
finding differences there they were not
wrong
just differences in the layer 22
just the region 22 are much larger we
can see decrease
in schizophrenia compared to control
vimentin which is a marker of
a specific neuronal marker of particular
cell types
and also very interesting discovery for
the
myelin basic protein because there are
some indications of
uh hyper myelinization
of area 22 based on the functional mri
data
and we can see actually wherever
especially in superficial layers
we can see very strong increase in
schizophrenia of a smile and basic
protein which involved in this
myelination of axons and this matches
very well published it and we're now
also going to do additional experiments
just to explicitly look
at this white matter
component of the quartets using
multi-imaging
which enables us to visualize
lipids which are there in the mining
which is what these are
another technology another spatial
technology which will complement this
one
and hopefully this is a result which
will be able to
support by additional data so this is
all what i wanted to show you today
we will definitely have more results
out of this wonderful data set but uh
uh which would require additional
experiments which are not doing
and i would like to thank nanostream for
enabling this work and of course to our
colleagues
from the psychiatrist centers which have
provided us with
the samples which we used in this
research and their expertise
and thank you all for your attention
thank you thank you very much philip
great presentation
we're going to take the questions uh
after the next presentation so
feel free everyone to post your question
in the q a
box that you see on the side of your
screen philip we are gonna take now at
home
you can rest for a minute don't go away
completely
and we'll see you for the questions
later so we're moving on on a quick
um audience interaction so if you would
like to
uh participate and take the next
paul it would be wonderful we would like
to hear from you
when you conduct facial research if
you're not doing it now in future
what analyte will you focus on or
are you focusing on is it rna is it
proteins
or is it both and we've done this same
um sort of uh poll in the previous days
and we
found very different answers actually
from the oncologist versus the
immunologists
that attended the previous two webinars
so it would be nice to see
the results now live so that we can
share with you
those as well
okay
another different question so we see
that rna and proteins have been selected
by all of you which is very very
interesting
excellent excellent thank you very much
so i would like now to
introduce our second speaker it's my
pleasure to
invite on camera john hugh who is the
senior lecturer
in cellular pathology at the school of
life sciences
university of westminster and the
honorary seniors research
fellow at division of neuropathology ucl
queen square institute of neurology
john research investigates the patho
mechanism
underlying structural pathologies
inflammation
and neurodegeneration in human epilepsy
and the title of the presentation is
single cell expression studies in human
focal cortical dysplasia so john thank
you very much
for being with us and we are all looking
forward to listening to your
presentation
thank you hello everyone um
thank you very much agnes uh for the
introduction
i'm very happy to be invited here to
present
my gene expression study on vocal
epilepsy
using nano strands digital spatial
profiling technology
i just want to acknowledge that this
study was funded by the horn family
cherishable
fun foundation through the epilepsy
society and the tissue used today
were obtained from the epilepsy society
brain and tissue bank
epilepsy is a chronic neurological
disorder
where patients experience spontaneous
and recurrent
seizures and a lot of them also
experience cognitive
and memory impairments which really
affects their quality of life
there's no cure for epilepsy patients at
the moment and for most patients
epilepsy can be controlled through
anti-seizure medication
however approximately a third of these
patients especially those with focal
epilepsy are refractory to drug
therapy so one alternative treatment
option for these patients
is epilepsy seizure whereby an area of
the brain
that initiates abnormal seizure
activations
are removed and the seizure region is
again in approximately 60 patients who
undergo these surgeries our research
group is
very interested in studying these
surgical resections from epilepsy
patients
and so that we can explore the
pathomechanism underlying epilepsy
but for the present study we are very
interested
to study specifically the brain
resections from patients with focal
epilepsy
and also focal cortical diplasia
pathology
focal cortical diplasia is one of the
most
common pathology findings in surgical
specimens of patients with focal
epilepsy
if fcd or photocortical diplasia can be
found
anywhere in the brain with about 51
of the cases observing stds located
in the frontal lobe this type of
cortical malformation can be categorized
into
three subtypes or tiers based on
clinical pathological criteria set out
by the international league against
epilepsy task force
in particular fcd 2b is
the specific pathology that we are
interested in
for this study that that's because fcd2b
is characterized by
really abnormal architectural and
psychoarchitectural
um differences in the cerebral cortex
and our main pathological findings in
these
specimens include cortical dye
lamination
radio neuronal disorientation
poor myelation in the white matter and
the presence of
abnormal cell type known as dimorphic
neurons and balloon cells
and these are the abnormal cell types
that we want to explore further on using
nano strings digital spatial
profiling technique and here you would
see
a image showing an h e or hematoxylin
stained
brain tissue section from a patient with
focal cortical diplasia
2b and you'll see in a that
there are a mark pale discoloration at
the bottom of the sulcus where the arrow
is pointing to and the fct is located
um particularly in the bottom of the
focus for this patient
and it's actually a quite common
location where
sdv can reside in most patients and in
this region
you would see that the clear declaration
between the gray and white matter is
lost
b is showing a really higher magnifying
view of the bottom for sulcus where the
std
is located in this patient and on the
either side of the sulcus you would see
that the six
normal six layer cortex is actually
disorganized now
and there's a lot of planomorphic cells
scattered throughout the gray matter
in particular you may actually see um
there's larger cells with larger
strongly stained and hematoxylin stay
nuclei
clustering kind of in the middle and
lower
cortical layers and an example is noted
around where the star find is located on
the image
and there's mainly actually abnormal
cells huge cells
that are found in the white measure
underlying the um
the gray measure that's located at the
bottom of the sulcus
and this is where the triangle signs are
located um
pointed to in the image here let's have
a look at these two locations
of interest in a high magnification
okay so in c you would see that there's
a high number of abnormal neuronal cells
known as dimorphic neurons
and these cells have a very large cell
bodies and nucleus up to
about 50 micrometers in diameter and
this is comparable to
normal neurons which are usually up to
about 25
micrometers in diameters and these
dimorphic neurons
are male orientated and they abnormally
aggregate um a lot of intracellular
missile substance
and which are just placed towards the
cell membrane and there's a lot of
cytoplasmic
accumulation of neural filaments as well
indeed we uh here you will see that
there's a large number of
paler large balloon cells they have this
glassy electronic
looking cytoplasm and the nucleus is
normally
disoriented to the proliferate and
sometimes
these cells are biomusculated or
multinucleated as well
so both of these abnormal cell types are
really best appreciated
using immunohistochemistry and dimorphic
neurons can be identified using a marker
for neural filament for example
smi-32 and vomiting
antibodies can then identify some of the
balloon cells
that we see in fcd brains receptions
in our previous studies we have found
that dimorphic neurons and balloon cells
also express
pas6 i'm showing you in tor activation
but it should be noted that smi-32
and vimentin and ps6 don't exclusively
um label these abnormal cell type
there's actually no
single marker that label these
particular cell types so that's why we
want to use
the um digital spatial profiling to
investigate these cells a bit more
more and and also
despite the many kind of std studies
around this area
we really don't know how these abnormal
cell types contribute
to epidural genesis and
so we are very interested um
to use um dps to learn more about the
gene expression profile of these cells
and how they differ to the
morphologically
normal appearing cells in the nearby
non-diplastic region of these tissue
and so to start our journey we contacted
our local neural string rep xavier and
tony
last summer to start the project it was
very exciting
um but here's a brief summary of the
workflow
so first we prepare five micrometers
thin um formula
fixed paraffin embedded a brain tissue
from four
cases of um fdd patients
who have similar scd-2b pathology
and in these cases we see a lot of
dimorphic neurons particularly in the
gray matter
and balloon cells particularly in the
white matter and also in the sub here as
well
and we sent our unstained tissue and
morphological markers
smi 32 enviromentan to the nanostring
team
um in the us so for example
um allison
and and her team uh was able to perform
digital spatial
profiling using um a panel called the
cancer transgenic
um panel and this panel consists of
about 1800 dreams
and the us team label our sections using
immunofluorescence
and the marker that we sent them and on
these
immunofluorescence label tissue we then
outlined our area of interest
and then we used a special segmentation
method
to actually um segregate
um these tissues so then they can be
further analyzed
using ds dspm um and he's a bit more
detailed about our
cases so we've got our four cases here
showing std2b pathology these cases
range from the age of 20 to 40 at age at
surgery we tried to use tissue for more
recent cases so we included two cases
from 2019
one case is from 2017 and one case is
from 2014
and the resection rule predominantly
from the frontal cortex with one case is
in the parietal cortex
and here's a closer up look at our
tissue
and from our four cases so
the dice plastic or scd region
is highlighted in yellow here and
these areas contain dimorphic neurons
and balloon cells
and i've also noted where the non std
regions are located
nearby to these regions but the non-std
regions contain morphologically normal
m neurons and glial cells so they don't
have the appearance
of these abnormal cell types that we see
in the fcd region
so we're interested in comparing really
three groups or elements first we're
interested in looking at the dream
gene expiration profile of the scd
region compared to the non-fcd region
next we are interested in comparing the
gene expression profile
of abnormal cell type dimorphic neurons
compared with
morphologically normal appearing neurons
in the non-std region
and then thirdly we're interested in
comparing gene expression profile of
balloon cells in std regions
compared to morphologically normal
appearing glial cells
in the non-fcd region to isolate
these particular cell type
and also region where we need to perform
and specialize segmentation
um logarithm so that we can select these
samples
um for dsp and these are
actually shown in image a and d
so for comparing std and non-std region
we just draw a circle in the area that
we want to
perform geometric segmentation on
and to compare um specific abnormal
dimorphic and balloon cell types
are shown in b and e and also
normal appearing um neurons and glial
cells
in non-fcd region are shown in cnf
respectively we draw three squares
region
um in those places and to get sufficient
tissue
for our abnormal and normal
appearing cells for digital spatial
profiling analysis
and as detailed in the workflow
the actual selection of the areas of
interest were conducted on tissue that
were labeled
using immune fluorescence marker against
smi-32
vimentin gfap and a nuclear stain as
shown in
a and b is a figure
showing std region which is encircled
for the geometric um region uh
and really for geometric um
segmentation and then i've also included
a square here
to show that that's the area that were
used for
rear cell segmentation and c is further
showing
how smi-32 dimorphic neurons are
segmented
from other cell type and tissue areas in
that region
so that dsp is only performed on
smi 32 cells and processes
from the std region as shown in this
image here
neurostand has a dpx
data analysis platform which we can then
visualize our data
and the platform is really user friendly
and you're able to actually select which
sample you want to visualize or
analyze and the data we've received
has been through sequencing and
biological pro
quality control and then normalized by
um
the nano string team
um so all the graphs presented here
today
actually generated from the digital
um spatial profiling data analysis
platform
and first here showing a principal
component analysis plot
and this is really interesting finding
because
our samples as you can see segregated
quite clearly into four distinct
clusters
so we've got the dimorphic neurons
clusters the balloon clusters at
opposite end from each other
and then we've got distinct clusters of
morphological
neurons in glial cells and when we plot
our
data um from the the um
the tissue that's been only analyzed
using the rear cell segmentation program
and we can still see these four clusters
very distinctly
in the pca plot but when we look at
the geometric data so this is just
looking at region and not looking at
self-specific um
information and we the the separation
between the four groups we're not so
distinct
so for the rest of the presentation here
i'll present data only from the cell
segmentation
um program we further did bob plot
to check to see if markers we expect to
be highly expressed in neurons
we're really indeed highly expressed and
here we can see that the neuronal
population dimorphic neurons
and the morphological neurons we're
highly expressing
neural filament light chain which encode
for
neural filament a form of it and and
the expression in these cell types were
higher compared to the balloon cells or
the glial population
and similarly when we look at cam kinase
2b
we see also a high expression of this
gene
in dimorphic and neuronal cells
compared to balloon cells and glial
cells
and looking at more kind of glial marker
it's a hundred b
genes we're highly expressed and kind of
the glial population of balloon cells
and clear
and then the neural uh dimorphic neurons
and neurons
um lamp one which is a lysosome
associated
membrane protein which were found to be
highly expressed in balloon cells in
previous disease
in this study here we do see a high
expression of this gene
and balloon cells and it was surprising
to note that that lamb1 expression was
also higher
in the dimorphic neuron population as
well
and we then perform heat maps and we can
see
very distinct clusters sets of genes
that were highly expressed as
represented in red and yellow here in
the heat map
and these genes were mainly from the
dimorphic
neuron population um and it was
interesting to see that
the same set of genes were actually down
regulated
in the balloon cell population
and vice versa when we look at the genes
that were up regulated
and the balloon cells they were down
regulated in
the dimorphic neurons and we further
um did some um more plots
using uh volcano plots and it shows kind
of similar foundings as seen in those
heat maps
and the left the plot shows kind of over
30
30 genes that were significantly
expressed over twofold change in the
dimorphic neuron population
compared to the normal appearing cell or
neuronal cells and the right plot you
would see that there's over
about 50 genes that were highly
regulated or highly expressed
and the balloon sales population
compared the glial population
and for the pathway analysis showed us
that um these genes they were up
regulated and um
balloon cells and also dimorphic neurons
seems to involve
kind of self-ignoring pathways and also
immune response pathways and we exploit
um exploring these pathways in more
detail
um at the moment so in conclusion
um this um dps study is very exciting
showed us very
interesting and also surprising data as
well
and but it does actually tell us that
the gene expression profile
of um transcribing profile of dimorphic
neurons and balloon cells
and stds are likely to be distinct and
different
from each other and also
from the morphologically appearing
neurons and glial cells
in non-std region and these changes in
gene expression seem to suggest that the
some signaling pathways and also
immune response pathways are involved
and our next step is to validate um the
digital spatial profiling findings
through rna scope or rna-ish
immunohistochemistry we have already
begun testing markers
that we can get and perform using
immunohistochemistry
and we do see a high expression of these
some of these genes that were
upregulated in dps and
immuno studies as well so it's very very
exciting
and we do plan to do more dsp probably
using
the world the wta panel
and it will be very exciting to see what
kind of results we
get there okay thank you everyone thank
you very much for your attention
thank you thank you very much john that
was another great presentation
and so i think we could take another
moment
to run a another poll quickly and then
we'll come on
all on camera uh to get the question and
answers
there is a little bit more time also to
post your question if you have
any uh please use the question box in
the screen
and they on the screen now you have the
poll what type of experiment do you
consider essential
to enable you to answer your scientific
question
so is it the bulk analysis is it the
single cell or the spatial profiling
if you would like to take the poll now
it's open
and we can see the results in a second
too
okay not many participated on this one i
don't think
uh so maybe we can take the poll away
and then go to the question and answers
for our uh presenters if you would like
to come back on camera
tony phillips and john
i have some questions for you that came
that come from the audience or let's
start
um let's start with actually
with you phillip so did you find a good
agreement
between the differences that you see in
the schizophrenia at the protein
and rna levels what was the condition
there
yes aggressive so uh indeed we
overall found good agreement but um
it's actually more than well because in
the brain
uh the rna and the proteins are
frequently in the different places
because cells are so extended over the
layers
so we actually saw several good examples
so for instance the
myelin protein we saw what most of rna
differences are in the deep layers
but most of the protein differences
actually in superficial layers
and now we're following up on that and
we see what this is actually the
difference between
actual difference between rna and
protein expression in
schizophrenia brain compared to controls
okay actually that leads me to the other
question that we receive around your
strategy
for the segmentation when you use geomix
for the reason that you just explained
the server to extend it
how what was your strategy in the
segmentation
well our strategy was very simple
because we actually
simplified with for ourselves in terms
of choosing
cortex neocortex of the brain and
there's
very well known anatomical segmentation
in two different layers
based on the cell histology and we
simply follow
with classical neurobiology
neurobiological segmentation which
already exists for
more than 100 years and based on the
segmentation we really
do get very different expression profile
and very
big differences among layers in terms of
schizophrenia yeah did you
last question for you before we move to
joanne what type of tissue do you use
did you use fresh frozen
or was it fixed it was fresh frozen
for sure okay perfect same question to
you john
use i think you mentioned what type of
tissue did you use
um we used um human tissue and
they are forming affects paraffin
embedded tissue so ffpe tissue
and this was quite important for us
because we are interested
in using fixed tissue for um to trial
these kind of molecular analysis because
ftd is actually quite difficult to
localize in fresh
or frozen resection and a lot of the std
is actually confirmed through
in the histochemistry on fixed tissue
using a panel of different markers
so we're definitely was very interested
in using ffpe
and see how um dsp actually perform
using this type of tissue
ah yes and then did it go well i guess
obviously yeah we're very happy yeah
definitely very happy with our results
and it's very interesting as well
and again on the sample um so talking
about the strategy for segmentation
would you recommend using the rare cell
segmentation
over the geometric segmentation what
what is your view
yeah but definitely i think the rear
cell segmentation really
um strongly popped up to us we when we
saw that it was
you know a bulb light up and we were
really excited to try this
but i think depending on what your
research in question
actually is will determine what kind of
segmentation you want to use
with our std specimens we have very
good distinct cell type that was
abnormal in std
and we want to really research on these
cells out them
specifically so using the cell recell
segmentation
is the really the best way to segregate
the cell population from other tissues
and other cell types
in previous studies we have used laser
capsule
micro dissection and proteomics using
frozen tissue and but that actually took
a really
long time and uh and
actually using the dps and also this
rear cell segmentation
that makes the whole study really more
efficient and um i think
and we trust because we've been through
the whole process ourselves with allison
and the nano strength
team over in the us we are really more
certain
uh of our results and what cell type
have been picked up and analyzed and dsp
okay we have a technical question tony
around the slides that
are to be used with geomics are they
special slides
and what type of slice also from
ffp what thickness yeah sure so
they are not special it is a classic
superfrost plus
slide which could be found really almost
anywhere in most pathology labs
if you're you can using a like a bond
system or have kind of
automated then we'd recommend a like a
bond slide
and then the thickness we we recommend
between four and
seven microns for uh tissue sections
perfect join another question for you
what is the clinical significance
your findings uh from these dsp studies
yeah um so sdd2b like i said before is
really
you know a common um malformation um
pathology that's observed in surgical
risk uh restrictions of
pediatric and also adult patients with
focal epilepsy
and previous studies have shown that
um neurons and balloon cells
are suspected to play a intrinsic role
in mediating
um seizure epileptic seizures and our
studies have shown that they're
activated
through the mtor pathway so getting to
know the genetic
profile or the transgenic profile of
this um cell type
would give us an important insight into
a signal transduction
and underlying the cellular dimorphic
or dimorph morphological differences
that we see in these cell types and how
it could contribute
to brain malformation and
hopefully subsequently are helping
with um kind of
development of kind of neural uh
therapeutic
interventions and secondly these like i
said before there's no really
exclusive marker that labels dimorphic
neurons and balloon cells and hopefully
by um looking at those results that
we've got and analyzing through
um very carefully um we can have
a kind of transcription oh make a
profile of these subtypes that can be
used and be very helpful for um
classification
okay last question for philip same
question actually the clinical
significance of your findings from this
experiment can you see a path to the
clinic
well i believe
we hope to have one of course it's a
very
basic science study looking at the
mechanism of schizophrenia
uh but it does help to look deeper
so for instance we already saw what it's
much more
effect on many brain regions which were
not
involved before in this implicated
before in disease
and uh now with the help of nanostrain
we also
see uh which layers have this effect
and whether they are replicated across
brain regions
um so it does help us to build a
more systematic view of the mechanism of
disease
and this would lead us to the
potential genes which might be
key regulators and i didn't show it to
this talk
but we indeed identify the number of key
regulators which
might be a guide in this expression
difference
which we detect and they were picked up
by the
genome white association studies
previously so
it is so potentially an
important study and we hope it would
shed light on the schizophrenia which
would allow us to move much further
beyond what we can do now
wonderful wonderful excellent so i want
to thank
everyone here the speakers uh all of you
pavel we didn't have question for you i
guess illumina is known to everyone
so thank you very much to the speaker
thank you to the audience who has been
following us
and we can now close we have a short
video to say goodbye to you
thank you bye-bye everyone bye-bye
[Music]
after completing slide preparation which
is similar to ihc or
ish we will put our slides into the tray
and then we'll put the tray into the
instrument and load buffer
next we will be ready to enter our slide
records and scan parameters
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a fluorescent image with up to four
colors is generated
to enable selection of region of
interest or roi on this tissue
you as the user can choose these rois
from anywhere on your laptop
geometric profiling allows us to choose
circles
squares or even polygons
this would be a great tool when you have
pretty homogeneous regions
like immune cells and the tumor
segregated within one tissue or across
tissues
in your cohort geometric profiling was
utilized in david lim's nature
communications article in 2020.
many users can also create rules for
segmenting the rois
this would let morphology of the tissue
determine the
boundaries of the area of illuminations
or aois to enable 100 cellularity
for example users can create
tumor and tme segments across a tissue
sample as shown on this example
selected rois are illuminated with uv
light to release barcodes from dsp
probes
and then these dsp probes are deposited
into a 96 valve plate
the release dsp barcodes are prepared
via a standard library preparation
so they can be read out on illumina
sequencers the data can be mapped
especially back to the originating
region of interest
samples can now be loaded onto your
illumina sequencer
depending on your experimental design
and the instrument capacity
you can read up to 760 rois from a
single geomix experiment
in a single illumina run here we have an
xc2000
which will allow us to easily read
hundreds of protein or rna analytes once
the task view files are generated
they'll be converted to digital code
comps and then uploaded back to
geomic.dsp instruments
the data analysis screen is divided into
three panes and a taskbar
here we describe the functions of each
pane and the interactions between all
three
this campaign is shown on the left side
and contains
illusively result stats in the middle
pane
we have our data sets and probe lists
on the right we have our visualization
pane
which shows the various graphs in this
case this is our
qc graph the middle data sets
pane lists all data sets and probe
groups associated with the current study
the visualizations pane is on the right
visualizations are visual
representations of the data set
selected and props selected and the
adjustments applied to the
data set from those probes now i'm going
to open another study
here we can see the data has been qc'd
and normalized
once you normalize the data you can see
in your visualizations pane
different graphs including pathway maps
pathway tables bar graphs correlation
plots
box plots pca flats
trend lines and we can view heat maps
i'm going to end with clicking on a data
point on the data visualizations pane
and you'll notice that roi associated
with it will be zoomed in
on the left pane of the screen
presenting seamless integration of the
images and the digital accounts
thanks for joining our customer
experience lab sessions
you